let me show you how we're going to be
using developer tools in this course I'm
running Chrome Canary and I have my
phone connected which I have just on the
side here with me you can see that I
have the Udacity site open let's inspect
that with the developers tools open
let's navigate to the timeline tab this
is where we're going to be spending most
of our time in this course next you can
actually enable the screencast feature
if you have your phone connected so
let's click on that and you can see a
preview of what's actually on my screen
as you can see it's the same picture to
record a trace we're just going to hit
reload and wait for chrome to capture
the full trace once the page is done we
have the full trace here and you can
expand and view all of the activity here
as well this is the view that we're
going to be using for most of the course
wow that's pretty awesome but what if I
don't have a phone handy I definitely
recommend using mobile debugging if you
have a phone handy but if you don't you
can record the same timeline data
directly on your computer check the
instructor notes for quick how-to